I want to give you some quick tips on
how to count respirations but first look
at this clip and tell me how many
respirations that you count in these few
seconds
okay you should have counted two
respirations now remember whenever
you're looking at respirations one rise
and one fall of the chest equals one
respiration and if the respiratory rate
is regular you can count for 30 seconds
and multiply that by two or if it's not
you can count for one full minute so
what is a normal respiratory rate well
in an adult is anywhere between 12 to 20
breaths per minute now counting a
respiratory rate can be tricky and you
want the patient to be unaware that
you're counting the rate so whenever you
get done taking the heart rate just keep
your hand there and then look for the
rise in the fall of the chest and then
sometimes you've really got to get close
to the patient and look at the side view
so you can see that rise and that fall
you may even have to take your hand put
it on their chest or their back to fill
the movement of the chest